sometimes poems end up being things you
don't initially intend I was asked to
write a poem about New Year's Day by NPR
years ago and i wrote a 36 line poem it
was quite elegant and i began to refer
it was broadcast i began to revise it
and revise it and revise it and it
finally ended up being a six line poem
that had nothing to do with new years
instead it was about how much of the
lives we lead are invisible to anyone
else the poem is called unsaid so much
of what we live goes on inside the
diaries of grief the tongue-tied aches
of unacknowledged love are no less real
for having passed unsaid what we conceal
is always more than what we dare
confined think of the letters that we
write our dead
you